youpi c'est un projet grandiose une cité
futuriste où tout est parfait des
professionnels accomplis qui peuvent
compter sur la fine pointe de la
technologie des familles heureuses et en
santé qui vivent loin du stress de la
vie quotidienne dans un décor
spectaculaire cet univers idyllique est
pour l'instant imaginer c'est le joyau
d'auckland réforme vision 2030 dont
mohammed bin salman le prince héritier
de l'arabie saoudite est l'architecte de
10,2 when you wear leveling pékin mais
avant de pouvoir servir d'exemple et
d'inspiration reste du monde comme le
dit cette vidéo promotionnelle
le royaume a beaucoup de chemin à faire
d'abord il a un urgent besoin d'argent
avec la fin du pactole de l'or noir
l'argent n'est plus à portée de main
comme avant une menace à l'état
providence qui offre aux saoudiens des
allocations du berceau au cercueil
rachida et son mari on en profite et
toute leur vie on est bien on a d'argent
même si une pauvre aulas d'argent et sur
l'arabie saoudite
même le pauvre elle a de l'argent parce
que la gouvernement
c'est elle qui paie tout ce qu'il veut
mais c'est un modèle qui n'est plus
viable en 2017 le budget de la
pétromonarchie accusé un déficit de plus
de 80 milliards de dollars
déjà l'état n'est plus aussi généreux
ils sabrent dans les dépenses
les saoudiens doivent se faire à l'idée
depuis janvier dernier de devoir payer
une taxe de 5 % la consommation
difficile pour certains à avaler
mohammed bin salman nds s'est donné une
mission vendre sa vision 2030 et faire
oublier l'image d'un pays intégristes
associé au terrorisme qui bafoue les
droits de l'homme et qui exécute
publiquement les condamnés à mort sur la
place publique les exécutions sont
toujours aussi fréquente sinon plus
mais les têtes ne roule plus les
vendredis sur cette place à ryadh
surnommé chop chop square a quant à lui
un nouveau pays est entraîné à
l'opération de séduction qui vise
essentiellement les investisseurs
étrangers
ravi cette pionnière du secteur privé en
arabie saoudite
la vision 2030 créer un climat favorable
aux investissements
nous voulons que les gens se joignent à
nous et nous met au défi pour qu'on
s'entende sur des termes bénéfique pour
les deux parties
bénéficiant
mais avec les réformes viennent aussi la
concentration des pouvoirs entre les
mains du jeune mds l'arrestation et la
détention de centaines d'hommes
d'affaires et de prince accusé de
corruption est un exemple ils ne sont
plus détenus dans cette prison dorée qui
leur était réservé au ritz carlton
les ententes secrètes auraient été
conclus des allégations de mauvais
traitements font surface
cette purge n'est pas le genre
d'événements a rassuré les investisseurs
et les entreprises étrangères
diversifier l'économie attirer des
investissements étrangers c'est une
chose mais le gouvernement de l'arabie
saoudite veut aussi mettre plus de
saoudiens au travail beaucoup plus un
défi de taille pour le relever il impose
de plus en plus de mesures coercitives
dans l'espoir de faire passer son
programme de nationalisations de
l'emploi à la vitesse grand v
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
seulement 3 million de saoudiens sur une
population de 30 millions par un emploi
la vaste majorité dans la fonction
publique les efforts pour ce qu'on
appelle la saoudisation de l'emploi
remonte à l'époque du roi abdallah mais
tardent à porter fruit dont le
gouvernement impose aujourd'hui des
quotas aux entreprises
[Musique]
c'est bien ce qui se passe parce que
personne ne peut développer le pays
comme les saoudiens il n'y a pas
d'espoir de développement si ce ne sont
pas les citoyens qui le baptise plus
devrait rester entre les mains des
saoudiens
des propos qui font part à samy un jeune
syrien qui né en arabie saoudite
il est tout juste diplômé en ingénierie
et voit les portes du marché du travail
se refermer sur ses ambitions
tous les étrangers ici sont inquiets et
réfléchissent à l'idée de partir en
turquie en europe peut-être au canada
n'importe où d'envisager de tout
recommencer ailleurs est une source de
stress
alors je crois qu'ils ont créé de
l'anxiété pour tous les étrangers
il nous invite à visiter l'un des seuls
chantiers actifs de la compagnie qui
appartient à son père pour laquelle ils
travaillent pour nous montrer le visage
actuel de l'emploi royaume pakistanais
philippines aux libanais pour chacun des
employés étrangers
les frais pour le droit de travail
imposées par le gouvernement de l'arabie
saoudite ont augmenté de 60% depuis
l'entrée en vigueur de nouvelles règles
et quotas la compagnie a dû licencier
certains de ses employés
malgré tout pas un seul saoudien en vue
ça me crois qu'il faudra encore beaucoup
de temps pour que cette image puisse
changer particulièrement ce qui a trait
aux travaux manuels
date soit rising au 15 avril as people
oggi qu'en disent les travailleurs comme
ceux ci seront les derniers à partir
parce qu'il ya très peu de saoudiens qui
acceptent de faire ce genre de travaux
manuels sur les médias sociaux on le
voit il rejette complètement la notion
la principale raison c'est qu'il ne
croit pas que c'était ils ont grandi
croyant qu'ils étaient au dessus de ce
genre de choses or dès 16 h 10 à ne
rougit pas de son travail elle le voit
au contraire comme un tremplin vers
beaucoup mieux l'accueil qui a été posté
juste humain et aux équidés année
socialement c'est mal vu parce que ce
n'est pas prestigieux mais les jeunes
sont plus favorables à l'idée
morgane et robben en échec aussi la
cimade à l'honneur on ne le fait pas
pour passer le temps mais plutôt pour se
bâtir à partir de rien notre culture a
changé il faut compter sur soi et ça
nous ouvre des horizons pour démarrer
nos propres projets d'affaires de
ballast aurait financé les propriétaires
d'entreprises ne sont pas mieux que moi
j'apprends et je vais moi aussi le
lancer en affaire à partir de rien
capables les nas libido vol c'est un peu
le pari de mohamed bin salman fait
renaître une toute nouvelle réalité en
arabie saoudite en imposant des réformes
économiques mais aussi sociales verglas
je suis vraiment heureuse que ça se
produise
c'est un rêve qui devient réalité et ça
va sauver notre pays qu économiquement
il fallait le faire de toute façon c'est
une question de coûts et bénéfices
surtout on voit la valeur de ses actifs
diminuer les saoudiens sont intelligents
ils sont rusés et nous sommes là pour
faire des affaires mais certains sont
sceptiques quant à la sincérité de ses
réformes
ils redoutent qu'il ne s'agisse
finalement que d'un mirage
[Musique]